well I was an entrepreneur and so the
advice I give to when I have people come
up and say how'd you do it what happened
with Under Armour do you pinch yourself
number one I don't pinch myself is
because I never woke up every day and
said you know can you imagine do you
think most importantly I never believed
it couldn't happen like and I'm not
saying we've finished and we sort of
reached the the goal line yet but we're
certainly you know we've got a great
head start and a lot of that was just
mentality you know I you know I heard
Larry Summers say something today - and
I reiterate it said it a different way
but optimism's of free stimulus and you
know stop reading the papers if you're
an entrepreneur and you do want to make
it your business go there's lots of
reasons that you can come up with why it
won't happen but you know I encourage
people to focus on you know why can the
other thing I'd say to any new
entrepreneur is be famous for something
you know like one thing we did at Under
Armour is people little-known fact is I
spent five years making one t-shirt
making it over and over and over again
and really making the product great and
you know I think so often people lose
focus like focus such an important
important criteria for anybody so I
could have used focus at 18 I would have
helped me maybe go to less high schools
would have helped me
maybe be a better student at some level
but look it all turned out all right and
you know I'm great to be here on on
Bloomberg go